evolutionary question number 24
what did darwin get wrong
about natural selection
ladies and gentlemen john perry here
i am
wanting to talk about
evolution by natural selection how
darwin viewed it and how people view
evolution by natural selection today so
how much of evolution by natural
selection did darwin get right
and we've just kind of been building on
and using ever since then and were there
things that he got wrong
and if so how wrong and in what ways and
i want to start by talking about
evolution as darwin understood it in
eight sentences
before i do that though before i present
to you those eight sentences i want to
talk about this bug that i found in
ecuador
this is a stick bug a stick insect
i was very impressed by its camouflage
because its camouflage is the result of
an extremely complex multi-trait
adaptation the specific type of
adaptation that darwin's theory
explains so first off compared to other
bugs even compared to some other species
of stick insect this species has an
elongated body
giving it a twig-like feel which hides
the fact that it is actually an insect
right hides it from birds and so on
other things that are looking for bugs
to eat aside from the elongation our
specimen has a beautiful green textured
coloring that helps it blend in on
pretty much any surface in the cloud
forest i found this in the cloud forest
of ecuador and last but not least it is
covered with little spikes which
probably function on their own as a
defense mechanism i mean if i were a
bird that ate bugs i would not want to
swallow this thing whole that's for sure
but more importantly these spikes help
break up the shape of the animal they
give it a mossy look its legs are almost
identical to the stringy moss that you
can see on this millipede photo that i
took the next day in the exact same
forest
camouflage this perfect with this many
independent cooperating parts cannot
simply poof into existence in a single
step darwin's theory of cumulative
evolution by natural selection is the
only natural process we know of that can
consistently produce multi-trait
adaptations with this degree of
precision
darwin figured out the process of
evolution by natural selection by
contemplating these types of multi-trait
adaptations and also he believed that
this explained
speciation how it is that new species
evolved in fact that was the title of
his book on the origin of species right
now i do want to point out before i get
into the the eight sentences that
describe evolution by natural selection
darwin was not the only person who came
up with this this is uh alfred russell
wallace right here a book of his that
i'm reading wallace came up with
evolution by natural selection
independently pretty much at the same
time that darwin did and other people
had been
talking about aspects of it before
there's there's other authors even
ancient authors that seemed to have
gotten parts of this right no one
really put it all together to figure out
how powerful the process was or at least
nobody put it together in a really clear
way
so clear that it convinced the
scientific community that this is how
things evolve darwin is credited for
doing that he did an extremely good job
putting this together explaining why it
matters so here are the eight
sentences describing evolution by
natural selection and i've broken them
into little sub sections as well so the
first subsection is descent with
modification when organisms reproduce
offspring are often similar to but
slightly different from their parents
and slightly different
from each other
keep that word slightly in mind because
i will talk about that here in a little
bit
some of the unique traits an organism
has are heritable i.e if they have
offspring many of those offspring will
display the trait that first showed up
in their parents
so that is descent with modification
you have heritable traits
that pop up darwin didn't know how they
pop up but they just knew they popped up
every once in a while and they were
heritable they could be passed on to
offspring number three and this is the
first sentence in my second category
under the struggle for existence
organisms tend to reproduce
exponentially but space and resources on
the planet are limited
this imbalance along with the naturally
harsh conditions of any environment
automatically produce a competition
known as the struggle for existence i
recently had a guy tell me that he did
not believe that the struggle for
existence is real that that's just
something that uh
darwin
thought existed because darwin was a
negative person you know
uh pessimistic
this is a forest behind my house
it's a bunch of silver maples that are
growing in this forest the beautiful
thing about this is you can see
perfectly the struggle for existence
kind of in comic book form different
frames in a comic book
so down here on the bottom we have
thousands of little trees little baby
trees that had been planted that spring
actually it might have been the spring
before when these seeds from the trees
fell notice that there are some spots
where there's lots of trees in some
spots where there are no trees seeds
fell pretty much everywhere but at this
stage the ones that are growing well
are the ones that happen to have landed
in the right neighborhood with the right
amount of water and the right amount of
sunlight
these are the trees that happen to be
fortunate enough
to experience what the kids nowadays
call
silver maple privilege
if we zoom out and look at the larger
trees the trees that actually survived
for several years we noticed that there
are far fewer of them far far fewer and
this is because there just are not
enough resources in this environment to
be one of the few that grows this big
that requires more than just being born
into the right neighborhood to get this
big you actually have to have something
special about you
internally
this tree might have been better than
its neighbors at growing fast it might
have been more resistant to fungus and
other parasites and might have been
better at using water and so on and then
if we zoom out further and look at the
actual adult trees there are far fewer
still
this is the struggle for existence
organisms reproduce exponentially but
they don't survive exponentially there
are limited resources in an environment
and there are just harsh conditions in
any environment to make it difficult to
survive in and reproduce in and so you
have this natural struggle for existence
it is undeniable the only way to reject
the struggle for existence is to reject
math like it's just basic
fundamental math just simple numbers
the planet is only so big
organisms reproduce exponentially
that can't happen forever
i think one of the reasons that people
get confused and they think that there
is not really a struggle for existence
is because
humans
the past several
hundred years
we keep pushing the limit on our
population further away through
technology the reality is that we exist
in a severe struggle for existence we
just
sometimes if we're really privileged we
don't notice that
before moving on i do want to say that
even though the struggle for existence
often leads to famine and can drive
animals to fight with steal from and
murder each other many species cope with
the struggle for existence in
surprisingly peaceful ways and if we put
our minds to it
we can too
that however is a different topic for a
different day for now just know this the
struggle for existence is no excuse for
being a
all right sentence number five
this is the natural selection section
novel heritable traits that happen to
make individuals less likely to survive
or reproduce will eventually be
eliminated in the struggle for existence
so those little trees that didn't quite
have what it took to grow in that little
bit of sunlight that was available to
them they will die
or even if they do make it to adulthood
they won't produce as many offspring as
the other trees and eventually over
multiple generations their lineage will
get snuffed out they will be overwhelmed
by their neighbors who are having more
offspring and also competing for that
same limited amount of sunlight number
six
novel heritable traits that happen to
make individuals more likely to survive
and reproduce within their environment
are automatically promoted in the
struggle for existence and there's
nothing magic happening here just the
things that can reproduce better become
more common than the things that can't
reproduce as good that's just how i mean
this is basic
again
simple math
there's nothing magic here nothing weird
here it's just that combination of
descent with modification acted upon by
natural selection differential survival
that's another way to say it
differential survival it's those two
things combined descent with
modification and natural selection
that are really special
sentence number seven those beneficial
traits now act as the new foundation
upon which future modifications can
build number eight the result is that
beneficial traits accumulate allowing
the generation of complex multi-trait
adaptations like we saw in the stick bug
and
even the production of new species
so that is how darwin understood
evolution by natural selection in just
eight sentences and now i want to talk
about what we what's changed since then
first off we now understand much better
why it is that or how it is
physically
that new traits develop
we now know that many of these
differences these new traits are due to
variations in genetic material
variations that are produced through
natural mechanisms such as point
mutation
gene duplication and recombination
when a new trait is the result of a
genetic modification an actual change in
nucleotide sequence that causes a
permanent heritable change in future
generations i should probably point out
that there are other heritable things
that an organism will inherit from its
parents that some people think that we
should include
in
our thoughts and discussions about
evolution the classic example is a
beaver will
modify its environment and then the
offspring will inherit that environment
along with the genes of the beaver and
some people think that that it's called
niche construction and that we should
really spend a lot more time focusing on
that as well in evolution
there's some evidence that certain types
of
modifications are temporary they're not
they're heritable modifications that
change the phenotype of an animal they
change the traits of an animal but they
are not encoded in the dna sequence
they're encoded in epigenetic
modifications to dna and they are
reversible so they'll only last for a
couple generations or maybe just like
two or so some people think that we need
to start thinking more about those
etc but
most of the research up until now has
been focused on changes in dna sequence
darwin was very focused on the internal
things that are inherited that end up
changing an organism's phenotype how
those can get passed on and how those
can evolve over time and so most
evolutionary biologists focus on
genetics when they're studying evolution
the other thing i want to point out here
is
the word slight
difference
so i say when organisms reproduce
offspring are often similar to but
slightly different from their parents
and slightly different from each other
darwin was even more extreme than me in
that sentence there in the first edition
of darwin's book he wrote natural
selection can act only by the
preservation and accumulation of
infinitesimally small inherited
modifications
each profitable to the preserved being
he goes on to say if it natural
selection be a true principle
it will banish the belief of the
continued creation of new organic beings
or of any great and sudden modification
of their structure so darwin focused
heavily on the idea that
the modifications that can happen from
generation to generation are extremely
small
and
studying domestic animals he knew that
sometimes the changes can be big i mean
big enough for like humans to notice
difference between one generation and
another but he thought that those large
jumps probably were never really
beneficial never often beneficial in the
wild and so they probably got selected
against as soon as they happened but
people like alfred russell wallace
argued against him they said actually i
think that fairly large jumps can happen
or at least jumps that are large enough
that we can actually notice them with
our own eyes they're not imperceptibly
small they're not infinitesimally small
sorry
infinitesimally small infinitesimal
apparently darwin listened to that
argument by wallace and by other people
who were making that argument because in
the later editions of his book he
removed that word infinitesimal the
later versions just say small
since then we've actually found
several cases of fairly large single
step jumps in evolution
one of them that's talked about in
textbooks a lot is there's
the way that a snail's shell curls its
chirality is what it's called that can
actually switch pretty easily in a
single step in a single mutation you'll
have a massive change in anatomy the
shell completely spins in an opposite
direction and that has a whole bunch of
consequences mainly the snell's ability
to reproduce with other members of its
own species that's one of the
interesting big immediate steps that we
know
can survive because we've found species
where populations are divided between
left-handed chirality and right-handed
chirality it's a pretty big step
certainly not infinitesimal
infinitesimal and i'll be having a guest
on here in a week or so who believes
that during the cambrian there was a lot
of changes that happened that if we were
to see them today we would say that
there were big changes people argue with
him on that a lot of people don't accept
his view there but it's interesting and
we're going to talk about that and i
think that if i were to rewrite darwin's
sentence here with what we now
understand about how big each step in
evolution can actually be i would change
it to say that natural selection can act
only by the preservation and
accumulation of probable inherited
modifications and i say probable there
because there are certain things that we
would see as being big steps
but actually if you look at the genetics
behind them it's it's really simple
things that changed in the in the genome
to cause a big effect
or
sometimes you have big changes in the
genome even so like a virus can can
insert a gene into the genome of an
organism and that can get into the sperm
line and so now you have an entire new
gene or in many cases many new genes
that are part of a species
genome now
that's a pretty big difference and we
know that that's happened multiple times
in the history of the the evolution of
mammals and that it's been important
it's actually
in some cases been adaptive
so the the insertion of an an entire
virus's genome into an organism ended up
being selected for by natural selection
so
there are things that can happen that i
would say are big jumps
either
big jumps phenotypically in the case of
the snail or big jumps genetically in
the case of a viral insertion that can
actually end up surviving and being
selected for again i change it to say
natural selection can act only by the
preservation and accumulation of
probable inherited modifications each
profitable or at least not harmful to
the preserved being if it natural
selection be a true principle it will
banish the belief of any great and
improbable modification in their
structure and how do we decide which
types of changes are probable and which
types are improbable well
we have to do lots of research and
figure out you know what types of
mutations are actually common a virus
insertion
seems like it's crazy a bunch of new
genes were added but actually viruses
are super common so a viral insertion is
actually a really common mutation
if we want to talk about what types of
morphological changes large
morphological changes are common we need
to study the physics of embryology
evolutionary development and so on and
there's lots of people that are doing
that and actually my guest who's going
to be coming on
in
a week or so is going to be talking
about that and he's finding there are
lots of modifications uh phenotypically
morphologically
that seem improbable but are actually
highly probable and could actually
happen in a single step the thing that
can't happen in a single step is the
development of a
multi-trait
adaptation where all the different
traits align for one function in the
case of our bug the function of hiding
from everybody looking like a mossy
stick that is undeniably something that
you need natural selection for you need
the accumulation of beneficial
modifications and the rejection of
harmful modifications what are the
questions that darwin was trying to
answer
he wanted to know how is it the new
species form
and he wanted to know
how was it that complex multi-trait
adaptations arise
what was the answer
descent with modification acted upon by
natural selection
these two
things combined
allow the accumulation of beneficial
variations beneficial modifications
while eliminating any negative
modifications that might pop up during
that time
there you have it
evolution by natural selection
i should probably point out that genetic
drift which is just kind of random
change that happens is also very
important in speciation and it doesn't
have much to do with natural selection
at all but that's a different story for
a different time
for those of you who are interested
i am planning another trip to ecuador
and you are invited it's going to be in
december the end of december so it
starts december 28th there's a link in
the video description where you can go
learn about the tour and like how much
it costs and
how to sign up and all that stuff it's
going to be pretty awesome my friend
nancy mairelli she is an entomologist
she will be guiding the tour and well
setting up the tour really we're gonna
have local people from ecuador actually
guide
individual tours we're gonna go on the
rain forest it's gonna be rad so
check that out in the meantime
spread love in this world
there's a lot of hate floating around
these days
gotta fight that
you